i'm very pleased today to be talking to
dr stephen pinker from harvard
university
he's the john stone family professor in
the department of psychology there and
is taught additionally at stanford and
mit
he's an experimental psychologist who
conducts research in visual cognition
psycholinguistics and social relations
dr pinker grew up in montreal and earned
his ba from mcgill and his phd from
harvard
he's won numerous prizes for his
research his teaching and his nine books
including the language instinct how the
mind works the blank slate the better
angels of our nature
and the sense of style
he's an elected member of the national
academy of sciences a two-time pulitzer
prize finalist a humanist of the year
a recipient of nine honorary doctorates
and one of foreign policies world top
100 public intellectuals and times 100
most influential people in the world
today
he's chair of the usage panel of the
american heritage dictionary and writes
frequently for the new york times the
guardian and other publications
enlightenment now the case for reason
science humanism and progress was his
10th and best-selling book published in
february 2018
and it's very nice by the way to have
the opportunity to speak with you again
and thanks very much for making the time
thank you jordan
so can i ask you it's been about a year
since we talked last and i guess i'd
like to ask you
first of all personally what's this year
been like for you you've become
uh a much more controversial figure i
would say than
would really be predicted
like
you you've always seemed to me to be a
solid reliable
interesting
mainstream scientist not someone who
would attract a tremendous amount of
critical
attention
and yet
you've become
well
oddly enough associated with
the intellectual dark web whatever that
happens to be and
so much of what you're doing is
controversial and so
what's that been like and what's your
life been like over the last while
yeah you wouldn't think that a defense
of reason science humanism and progress
would be
uh incendiary and i'm hardly a
flamethrower and as you note i have
put forward some pretty controversial
ideas in the past such as that uh men
and women aren't indistinguishable that
we
uh all harbor some unsavory motives like
revenge and dominance but saying the
world has gotten better turns out to be
a
radical inflammatory hypothesis there uh
there are
there's first of all just sheer
incredulity because the view of the
world that you get from journalism is so
different from the view of the world
that you get from data because
journalism reports everything that goes
wrong it doesn't report things that go
right and so if there are more things
that go right every year there's just no
way of
learning about it if you get your view
of the world from the papers and so
there's just sheer disbelief but on top
of that there are intellectual factions
that are committed to the idea that the
world has never been worse than it is
now and uh data on human progress
undermines uh some of their their their
foundational beliefs and and so that
does attract uh some some opposition
people think of it as a defense of
neo-liberal capitalism or a defense of
uh the opposite secular humanism and
traditional liberalism and so it does
get some people
uh exercised uh
basically anyone if you're a social
critic if your reputation comes on
saying what's going wrong about uh the
current society
then um you're kind of committed to the
idea that things have gotten uh gotten
worse and uh the idea that things are
not as bad as they used to be not as bad
as they could be is an insult to that
those core beliefs
yeah well it's it's a surprising thing
because well and so so let's let's talk
about that a little bit i mean here's
some of the things i know
i think i know
and maybe you could describe some of the
things you know and like i started
learning that the world
had been improving when i worked for a
un committee about five years ago now
and started looking at the
data on
ecology and sustainable economic
development and that's like there's some
bad ecological news i i think that what
we're doing to the oceans is
fundamentally unforgivable and and
foolish beyond belief but there's some
ecological news that's of
surprising
positivity like there was a paper
published in nature not so long ago
stating for example that an area twice
the size of the u.s has greened in the
last 15 years i think it was last 15 or
20 years that actually happened to be as
a consequence of increased carbon
dioxide because plants can keep their
pores closed if there's more carbon
dioxide and so they can live in more
semi-arid areas and
there's more forests in the northern
hemisphere than there were 100 years ago
and more forests in india and china than
there were 30 years ago and then this
has gone along with a massively improved
stem standard of living um
the child mortality rate in africa is
now the same as it was in europe in 1952
which is a statistic that i just regard
as absolutely miraculous the african
economies are growing sub-saharan
african economies seem to be growing
faster at the moment if the stats are
reliable than
economies anywhere else in the world
partly because the africans are getting
connected electronically and have access
to reasonable information into something
approximating let's say stable currency
alternatives
um
there there's
people are people the the rate of
poverty is diminishing at an amazing
rate right we we have poverty
considering it at a dollar 90 a day
between 2000 and 2012 and i've read
criticisms of that saying well that was
an arbitrary number but if you look at
380 a day
you see the same
decline if you look at 760 a day you see
the same decline not as precipitous and
even the u.n
not known i would say for its optimistic
prognostications estimates that
at this rate
by the year 2030 there won't be anyone
in the world who's living below the
current poverty level
so
so there are some positive statistics so
what what what would you like to add to
that
oh yes and those are all of those those
numbers are reported in graphs in
enlightenment now but also uh what else
um
illiteracy is declining
um rates of
of uh violent crime including violence
against women and children are declining
child labor is declining uh death and
warfare is declining uh people have more
leisure time they have more access to
small luxuries like here
and uh
getting affording our plane fare uh so
it's
funny that that all of these um examples
of human progress which one would think
vindicate the attempt to make the world
a better place it's not just do-gooding
it's not romantic it's not utopian we
really can improve the world if we
set our minds to to do it should arouse
so much anger
partly because they
people are so unused to thinking that
things have gotten better that they
confuse it with
uh
certain kinds of magical thinking such
as
that things get this must mean that
there is a force in the universe that
that uh carries us ever upward that just
makes progress happen by itself which is
the exact opposite to reality the the
universe not only doesn't care about us
but it has a number of features that are
constantly pushing back at us like like
entropy like uh um like pathogens
like entropy is a bad one
entropy is is the uh
is the root of all human suffering
ultimately so the universe doesn't
care about us
i i've read too other things that are
peculiar that are so interesting and
well okay so first of all um
it's pretty hard on the marxists i would
say
because
even though there is inequality and
inequality is a problem
first of all it doesn't look like
inequality can be placed at the feet of
capitalism it seems to me to be a far
more intractable problem than that
second
it's clear that the poor are getting
richer despite the fact of inequality
and third and this is hard on the
environmentalists i think is that
it turns out that if you
get people's income up to about five
thousand dollars a year in terms of
gross domestic product they actually
start to care about the environment
which i suppose is because they're not
worried about dying instantly that day
or that week and so we we seem to be in
this perverse situation for a pessimist
where
we could make people
wealthy
and
in in a positive manner
and we could
make the world a better place
simultaneously and
that does seem to be very hard on
ideologues whose
ideology is predicated on a fundamental
pessimism or you get the other people
like the biologists do this sometimes
and say well yeah we're purchasing all
this short-term prosperity at
you know for these billions of people
but at the cost of some medium to
long-term eventual precipitous you know
apocalyptic collapse and it's very
difficult to formulate an argument
against that kind of
idea because
well you never know when
some i i think this is one of the things
talib takes you to task for doesn't he
yes even though i i actually have pretty
extensive coverage of the of tail risks
both in the better angels of our nature
and in enlightenment now
and indeed we do uh we cannot take uh
incremental improvement as itself an
indication that the um risk of
catastrophes is at an acceptable level
and it may not we uh it's very hard to
estimate what the risk of a catastrophe
is but there are certainly some that we
that we ought to take very seriously
but you know on the other hand
the uh the facts that you mentioned
uh
are often resisted by particularly
people in the green movement i'm just
going to lean down and pick up my earbud
which rolled across the floor
[Music]
uh but if if anything it should give
hope and sucker to the environmental
movement because it shows that it is not
true that we have to choose between
economic growth which people do not want
to give up and protecting the
environment that uh that we can have
both and indeed there are some ways in
which they go together the uh nations
that have done the most to clean up
their environment in the last 10 years
are the wealthiest nations because they
can afford it if you're dirt poor as you
mentioned
your first priority is putting food on
the table and a roof over your head and
the you know the fate of the white
rhinoceros is pretty gonna be pretty low
on your list of priorities and you might
be willing to put up with some smog in
order to have electricity it's really
awful to do without electricity and and
i know having visited cities like uh
mumbai which are horribly polluted uh
and and that they are awful but it would
be much worse to not have any
electricity but on the other hand when
you get more prosperous then you're
willing to spring for the cleaner energy
and you can afford the cleaner energy
and as you mentioned your
values tend to climb a hierarchy and
more
uh long term
future concerns move larger in your
value system so it's an odd assumption
that both the hard right and the hard
green have in common which is that if we
want to protect the environment we have
to sacrifice prosperity go back to a
simpler more peasant
style of life
the hard greens say well that we've got
to give up uh modernity give up
capitalism go back to living living off
the land the uh hard right says well i
don't want to do that no one wants to do
that so to hell with the environment
the reality is that if both policy and
technology are deployed intelligent as
they ought to be then we can afford to
protect the environment
without going backwards and foregoing
all of the uh benefits of modernity
right well i was i was shocked when i
started to
learn about this the fact that there was
so much good
both economic and ecological news
um with the economic news perhaps being
somewhat better than the
ecological news
it doesn't mean that we can sit back and
relax and the environment will clean
itself up uh all by itself uh quite the
contrary we know why the environment got
better combination of policy like the
clean air act and clean water act in the
united states in 1970 and technology
like catalytic converters and scrubbers
and and uh clean energy so it doesn't
happen by itself the fact that it has
one of the great fallacies in people's
understanding of progress that they
equate the existence of progress with
progress happening
all by itself as
if it was some force of the universe
which is uh
contrary to uh reality the other you
mentioned that the existence of human
progress uh
is a blow to
dr near marxist which is certainly true
because we have seen the spectacular
economic growth of india and china when
they liberalize their economies and the
disasters of say north korea with a
beautiful control group south korea same
geography same resources same culture
same language same history
what differentiates them is their
political system and south korea is a
much better place to live it's not only
freer but it is also uh enormously uh
more prosperous
to debate slav
on the 19th of april and i've been
preparing for that you know and i
thought what i might do to begin with is
list
there's a graph that i think
humanprogress.org put out um it might be
matt ridley's graph or maybe hans
is it hans rosling rosling it may be
it's mariam toupee is the proprietor
right but it's what they call the most
miraculous most important graph in the
world which shows this unbelievable
acceleration of human prosperity
basically kicking in exponentially
around 1895.
yes a little bit earlier but uh this is
a combination of data sources including
um a a a late historical economy angus
madison who began the madison project
trying to retro retrospectively estimate
uh gdp per capita in eras where they did
not collect those data at the time by
using historical data yes it is
astonishing and i'm going to say when i
first saw that curve when i was working
on better angels more nature
i was stunned i mean this is the
original hockey stick yes that's the
hockey stick that very little economy
until the industrial revolution and then
then it uh shoots up exponentially
right right and so you know i look at
that and i think well look i mean
what's the issue here we still have
inequality but you can't put it at the
feet of capitalism because it seems to
be a much more fundamental mechanism
well these poverty certainly yes
yes well now well and even inequality i
mean that there seems to be this
proclivity towards the unequal
distribution of phenomena
not just
monetary phenomena but i mean
if you look in virtually every domain of
human endeavor that's associated with
creativity you get a pareto distribution
of productivity you know i mean a small
number of basketball players
shoot the vast majority of the hoops and
a small number of record
uh recording artists record the majority
of the hits and a small number of
planets have most of the mass and like
there is this i i mean i'm not trying to
make a case that inequality isn't a
problem i'm trying to make a case that
it's a way deeper problem than the
marxists presume and then you have the
other problem that well the poor keep
getting richer i mean half the world is
middle class now and obesity is a bigger
problem than starvation and so
when when i'm talk i can't i'm really
having a hard time
trying to understand
what the marxists have left as a
doctrine it's like well the problem you
guys were identifying seems to not exist
anymore
yes so part of it is that their foil is
a kind of
um
iron randian
objectivism
in which you have a pure
untrammeled uh unconstrained market
capitalism with no regulation and no uh
social safety net now one of the
discoveries that i made
which was almost as surprising as the
the hockey stick graph of prosperity is
the fact that in the 20th century
every developed country every rich
country
went on a spree of social spending and
so that from a baseline of about 1.5
percent of gdp redistributed to children
and the poor and the elderly and the
sick now the
median oecd country redistributes about
of its prosperity and all which
countries are in a band from about 20 of
gdp to about 30 gdp uh the united states
is at the low end uh actually canada to
my surprise our home in native land is
actually a bit lower than the united
states
people figure that out even though
canada would appear to have a more
generous welfare state than the united
states and in fact the united states
would be even higher if you added all of
the socialism that is done through
employers like retirement and health
insurance which in other countries has
done through the government but even if
we just looked at government
redistribution there just does not exist
a wealthy country without a an extensive
social safety net for a number of
reasons here's the theory you tell me
what you think about this
so
i've been trying to
let's say steal man
the
positions of the left i don't mean the
radical left i mean the moderate left
because i believe that the dialogue
between the moderate left and the
moderate right is what keeps
our ship
stabilized essentially and for this
reason so
imagine people have to group together
cooperate cooperatively and
competitively to solve difficult
problems because we have difficult
problems that's entropy let's say and
and the assault of the natural world so
we have to group together when we do
that we create hierarchies and we do
that in large part we hope
by elevating those who are the most
competent at solving the problems to the
higher positions in the hierarchies now
that can be contaminated by power and
tyranny and crookedness and poor
selection and all of that poor
measurement but fundamentally if your
hierarchy is functional the more
competent people rise to the top now
that produces the advantage of solving
the problem
but it produces the disadvantage of
making a lot of people stack up at the
bottom of that hierarchy because that's
what tends to happen because of the
pareto distribution and the and the the
built-in proclivity for inequality so
the answer to that seems to be
well we produce the hierarchies we
accept the inequality but then we attend
with some degree of clarity of vision
and care to those who are dispossessed
by the necessity of the hierarchies and
your claim seems to be from what you
just said is that that's essentially
what we've been doing in civilized
democracies for the last 100 years and
that that seems to be
roughly working
well it is yes uh that's right now
whether or not the hierarchies are uh
are optimal in the sense that we're
better off with the hierarchy uh because
of just what will happen in a
distributed market economy it you may
have winner-take-all situations where
the
uh the most entertaining story the most
efficient car the best washing machine
in a global market will push out a lot
of the competitors and so you get that
greater distribution whether or not it's
uh
anyone would have designed it if they
were to plan the entire society might
even be beside the point as long as you
don't have central planning and
distribution it might naturally result
uh if it is not explicitly uh opposed
which which some of our policies do uh
as you mentioned
it's a little bit like the like
environmental progress in that
far from being in opposition to economic
growth it's often economic growth that
uh
lets people become more munificent more
generous there are a number of reasons
why every wealthy country has a social
safety net and why as countries get
richer like brazil and india and china
they
turn their attention to
more social welfare
uh the the the european and north
american societies did it in the 20th
century and the developing world is
following suit partly it's because some
of the investment in some of the
redistribution is investment it's a
public good it's really good if the
entire population is educated for
everyone including the people who are uh
hiring them
and so some of it is just investment in
public
one interesting goods on the marxist
position because
the funny thing is is that
you know you lived in montreal i lived
in montreal montreal is a
relatively
flat city in some sense in terms of its
economic distribution like there are no
pockets of
terrifying poverty at least on the
island and it's a very safe place
and and so it's socially rich in some
sense like i always felt wealthy when i
lived in montreal even though i was
living on a
phd's
um
uh stipend which was very area the area
we used to call the student ghetto which
now has uh luxury condominiums right
right well but what was so lovely about
montreal was that
it it was safe
it was beautiful
and it had an unbelievably vibrant
public culture
yes and that was all there was all a
consequence of the fact that people
generally speaking were well enough off
and so
you know if you contrast that with a
country like brazil
where a tiny minority of people have all
the wealth well they're stuck with the
problem of living in gilded prisons they
have to move their children around in
helicopters and like
i think one of the things that people
realize
as societies become richer is that
it's better to calculate your wealth on
a broader level to include more people
within the purview of what constitutes
wealth for you because it's so nice to
be in a city that's thriving and and and
healthy and
and and not crime ridden and resentful
and and those need to be factored in as
elements of individual wealth
that's right and there is a um a debate
among social scientists as to whether it
is inequality that drives these other
social goods such as low crime
such as
public investment such as education or
whether it's prosperity it's not so easy
to tell them apart because in general
poorer countries like south africa and
brazil have sky-high inequality
countries like norway and sweden and
switzerland which have less inequality
are also pretty rich
and it isn't so easy to to see which one
is driving it because as societies get
get richer um as we've discussed uh they
tend to redistribute partly out of um
investing in a public good um such as uh
lower crime such as having an educated
populace is just a really good thing
partly it is literally insurance and the
euphemism social safety net uh that is
something that catches you if you fall
captures the idea that even when people
are well off they worry that uh they're
there but for a fortune go i that that
uh you gotta be nice to people on the
way up because you might need them on
the way down and so putting a
bottom uh a floor on how poor you can be
makes everyone feel a little more secure
that if the worst thing happened they
would not be destitute yes one but also
that's a second
it's not that uncommon for people who
are in the top 10
say of the economic distribution or even
in the top 1
to suffer a substantial reversal of
fortune at some point in their life and
it's a very rare person a very very rare
person who isn't at
economic danger of economic disadvantage
at some point in their life for some
reason well certainly people move in and
out of the the top decile top 10 percent
of the income distribution
although this argument for
social spending uh would be to indemnify
people against the worst outcome i don't
think that many people in the top tenth
or to say nothing at the top one percent
will ever go on welfare but still a lot
of people in the middle class can
imagine it and they don't want to think
that they'll be out on the street if
they they lose their job or if they have
uh suddenly suffer a big medical expense
then the third reason after uh
investment and insurance is just um
compassion or empathy we see in the
history of the west
after the industrial revolution you get
a a literature of uh of compassion for
the poor you you have uh the little
match girl you have les miserables and
john valencia in prison for stealing a
bit of bread to save his sister you have
the uh
uh the the jones bearing grandpa on the
side of route 66 in uh grapes of wrath
and so people
are also moved by sheer fellow feeling
with their uh
with their compatriots their fellow
citizens yeah but maybe maybe that's
another reason why the people who
are criticizing your
um informed optimism are irritated
because you know if your fundamental
political doctrine insists that
well
every
your primary identity is your group
whatever that happens to be
and the primary
um
motivating factor for the function of
your group is raw naked power
played out within that group against all
other groups the introduction of
something like the notion of an implicit
compassion
for the downtrodden
seems to like wreak havoc with the
purity of that ideological position but
like i've never met anyone in my life
and i know a large number of
extraordinarily successful economically
successful people i've never met anyone
in my life
who
walks down the street and sees a down
and out alcoholic who's clearly
suffering terribly as a consequence of
dwelling on the street
what would you say celebrate the
justice of the universe in elevating
them above that person who's
suffering i mean i think well
go ahead i mean we do know from from
social psychology that there is a
tendency to
um
to blame the victim to believe that in a
in a just world so i think those are two
uh motives that we have compassion for
everyone but also a feeling that that uh
those who are uh badly off must have
done something to uh to to deserve it we
we do see this of course in the surveys
that you and i are following well you
see a tension there because of course
the attention i think that's right
it's also modulated by um by some degree
of ethnic solidarity and it's been noted
that some of the generous welfare states
of europe have at least historically
occurred in countries that are
ethnically more homogeneous are
certainly racially more homogeneous than
the united states which tends to be
somewhat stingier now this is not uh
there is some elasticity into what we
cognitively categorize as our group and
one of the great achievements of any
kind of nation building is to uh is to
instill a feeling well we're all
canadians or we're all swiss or well
we're all uh iraqi something that has
actually not happened in iraq which is a
big problem uh if you unless you have
that fictional family that fictional
clan of nation then people tend not to
cooperate including you in ways of um
providing social welfare for for the
worst off
that's a ridiculously interesting point
i would say because
one of the things that you really see in
canada for example and our prime
minister is a real devotee of this idea
is that there really is no
canadian culture there's no central
canadian ethos and what we have is a
plurality of multicultural microcosms
and that that's actually all for the
best
yes the canadian mosaic as opposed to
the melting pot isn't very ideal
the prime minister's father pierre eliot
trudeau famously tried to forge a kind
of canadian identity that spanned uh
english the anglophone and francophone
communities hardly exemplified in
himself because he was a dashing
charismatic figure was distinctively
canadian he just wasn't he wasn't french
he wasn't american he had the rose in
his lapel he wore a cape he was
perfectly bilingual he was debonair and
witty and charming we all felt at the
time i remember this i remember trudeau
mania we all felt now that is a canadian
that's something to aspire to and he did
with his policies and with his symbolism
forge a kind of canadian consciousness
above and beyond the mosaic of the
lebanese canadians and the italian
canadian jewish canadians and so on well
it's with sufficient um what would you
call it success to at least keep the
country together which was something
quite remarkable
well he had to at one point he had to
declare martial law to do it yes during
the october crisis when um separatist
terrorists kidnapped
uh a trade commissioner and a government
minister
right a dark day for canada well so so
look it looks like there's a there's a
contradiction maybe and you can tell me
what you think about this
in the in a certain element of leftist
doctrine because
assuming that multiculturalism
is can be reasonably viewed as part of
the leftist doctrine
if it is the case that people are more
likely to be generous
to those that they see in some sense as
their in group
then what it suggests is that you need
to take the
mosaic
of of your culture the
african canadians and the european
canadians and the asian canadians the
same in the us
and have them maintain their their
culture and their traditions
but also to embed them
inside a broader game
that constitutes the national identity
that unites them all despite their
differences and
it seems like given what you just
described that unless you can
forge that
trans ethnic or trans-racial identity
that you motivate people to be less
generous in their social policies
so well that that is true and i i
consider this to be one of the the
key ideas of uh coming out of the
enlightenment opposed by the
counter-enlightenment of the 19th
century by the romantics and the
nationalists um that the uh that
a
a state a group of people under the
jurisdiction of a government are held
together basically by a social contract
by agreement that we're all in this
together there are many public goods
that we that we share public costs that
we can suffer
a government that uh
allows us to
to get along by serving in our interests
is a way of improving our welfare it's a
very different conception of a nation
than the blood and soil nationalism of
the uh of the 19th century continuing
well into the 20th that what makes us a
nation is that we're all uh we're all
white we all speak we uh come from a uh
same ancestry and that the successful
nations are often ones that manage to
forge the somewhat artificial identity
so that's also fascinating because then
okay then we got two arguments here for
that
for that um
let's say artificial or conceptual
nation nation-building
process
one is that
maybe you can allow people in their
different ethnic and racial groups to
maintain key elements of their identity
and and and feel comfortable doing so
but also embed them in a broader game
like again militarily played and laid
out but exactly by the same token
given your logic
that's also the most effective antidote
to the kind of nationalism that is
identitarian that also seems to be in
the resurgence
and you see this i really see this as
having been done extraordinarily
effectively in the united states now
they had the advantage of the examples
of england and france but that the
american
experiment was an experiment in
conceptual
nation building it's like here's a set
of principles that we can all agree on
despite our differences and to the
degree that we decide that we will agree
on these
principles then we're the same enough we
can cooperate we don't need to revert to
nationalism or or very much in the
declaration of independence that was
made crystal clear that to pursue uh
life liberty and pursuit of happiness
governments are formed with the consent
of the governed to allow people to to
flourish to prosper nothing in the
declaration said anything about the
european the white the protestant being
being christian it was really a social
contract
set up for first principles which of
course they had some pretty big problems
with of course the uh the african
citizens it took quite a while to work
that out and there were tensions uh in
the 20th century with ways of
immigration from uh from ireland from
eastern europe from
jews from italians and there were of
course tensions between the the italians
and the irish
but by the standards of human history
they got worked out pretty well i think
capitalizing on a feature of our
psychology which is that even though we
do have an in-group favoritism we do
have tribalism what counts as a tribe is
pretty uh elastic it is not by skin
color uh we form coalitions that cut
across skin color and a successful uh
country is one that capitalizes on that
elasticity form a a
virtual tribe which is simply every
citizen of the country and then
ultimately every citizen in larger units
including the
humanity including
all the world a lot of this depends
though on undermining certain features
of human nature such as kin solidarity
and it's been noted that in cultures
that have a lot of cousin marriage where
you're related to
people in your clan it's rather hard to
do nation building there like in
iraq for example people don't have a
sense of superordinate loyalty to a
coalition above their blood relatives
and they are tightly tied to blood
relatives by uh cousin marriage but this
also played itself out in the history of
the united states and there's a
wonderful snatch of dialogue at the end
of the first godfather movie when
michael corleone
enlists after pearl harbor
and his brother sonny says what did you
go to college to get stupid your country
ate your blood you're going to die
you're going to you're going to be a saf
who dies for strangers
and that is a perfect
encapsulation of the difference between
traditional tribalism
and the
mentality that we need for successful
right well so it sounds like it's you
know it sounds like one of the ways to
combat
right-wing identitarianism that the new
emergence of right-wing identitarianism
is to make that conceptual distinction
between national identity that's
predicated on blood and soil let's say
kinship direct kinship or
or even secondary kinship and these
these more abstract conceptions now it
seems to me so just don't just
you may know this or you may not but uh
ben shapiro's new book is number one on
the new york times bestseller list
and i read ben's book a while back and i
think it shares some features
with your book and it shares some
features with my book and i would say
the features it shares with my book is
that i stress the importance of
the judeo-christian
stories as part of that conceptual
substructure that unites a civilization
and then it has features in common with
your book because it's also a pro
enlightenment
manifesto
celebrating the achievements let's say
of the greeks and the rationalists
moving forward from there like shapiro
sees our culture as
and this is something that i agree with
i would say as a marriage between that
judeo-christian tradition and that
emergent enlightenment
you're
and it stopped me if i'm wrong but your
emphasis so let's say that we're playing
this
abstract conceptual game that unites us
as a people independent of our ethnicity
and our race
and there are principles
that
constitute the game rules for that
agreement and you see those as primarily
deriving from the enlightenment and and
starting then
well not i mean there's nothing new
under the sun and certainly some
enlightenment ideas had uh precursors of
the
in the uh the renaissance and in ancient
greece but that set of ideas that that
came together then it needed of course
further elaboration i think that that's
much more of a
basis of human progress than the
judeo-christian tradition
again any every uh
every intellectual movement draws from
pre-existing ideas and movements and so
there was some uh cherry-picking from
from the judeo-christian tradition but
uh it certainly did not depend on belief
in jesus christ our savior it did not
depend on a uh one god as opposed to
many gods really dependent on human
well-being life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness that's something you can
believe in regardless of your
theological commitments so what what do
you think so here here's the um
question i have about that is that like
it seemed to me so that the the
people who formulated the declaration of
independence for example
accepted as self-evident that human
beings were
intrinsically valuable and
the locus of
sovereignty insofar as they were the
citizens who would determine the course
of the nation and there's some
recognition there as far as i'm
concerned of
intrinsic value
outside of a rational argument you know
it as a as a
as an a priori presupposition we accept
these truths as self-evident right
and and and the
the most fundamental truth of that is
that it's something like in my
view
it's something like the
strange metaphysical
equivalence of man before god the fact
that we all have intrinsic value and
that's where i see the enlightenment
being
irreducibly
embedded inside this underlying
structure and that's that's different
than the idea of progress which is
something that that you're
focusing on and that i think
is more attributable to the development
let's say of science and technology but
it still seems to me that
the enlightenment had to have an under
structure
that enabled it to emerge
for those self-evident truths to be
accepted universally as self-evident and
well except i i agree that they're that
those aren't scientific ideas this is
these are the set of ideas that i uh
draw together under the the uh rubric of
humanism it's not clear that um
that the self-evident right to life
liberty the pursuit of happiness is
particularly judeo-christian in fact i
think i don't think you could find that
in uh scripture and in fact in the
jewish tradition uh god shows the jews
we're the chosen people so the idea of
universal uh of uh
human uh worth and well-being it's not a
particularly uh jewish notion it's a
particularly christian notion you've got
to it's only you you have to accept
jesus in order to uh escape
eternal damnation none of that's in the
declaration
what's self-evident is are the things
that are almost prerequisite to even
considering uh what ought to go into a
country or anything else namely you've
got to be alive rather than dead uh
you've got to be able to
express
opinions in order to even have that
conversation so you've got freedom
happiness as we know from from uh
evolutionary considerations is basically
the set of motives that kept our
ancestors alive and allowed us to come
into existence in the first place
combating uh the grind of entropy so i
think that the
foundation of that enlightenment belief
is not particularly judeo-christian but
more existential it just comes from what
are the actual prerequisites to being a
uh incarnate reasoning uh creature okay
so
i'm gonna press you
on two uh elements of that and i'm i'm
not
disagreeing with you by the way because
i'm not convinced that i'm right
it's just that these this is how things
have laid themselves out for me in my
thinking i mean
one of the things that's very
interesting about the book of genesis is
that it insists that human beings are
made in the image of god and that that
gives them
an intrinsic value and that they're made
in the image of god regardless of
whether they're male or female
and then
i know the jews emerge as the chosen
people
in the old testament but there's also a
strong
idea a powerful conceptual idea in the
old testament that emerges that the
people of israel the true israelites are
those who wrestle with god so it's like
it's like an it's like an existential
adventure it's partly based on blood
it's partly based on ethnicity but
there's a conceptual idea too there that
there's the the struggle for ethical
endeavor let's say and the struggle for
for for the discovery of the meaning of
existence is actually what marks out the
true follower of god
and then
as judaism transforms itself at least in
some part into christianity
what i see happening is that
you you get the idea that that
identity with god
that existed in genesis that that that
intrinsic value
starts to become more humanized that
really manifests itself sort of fully in
the renaissance that that the religious
figures start to become more individual
and that the idea that each individual
does in fact have
a divine worth
that that keeps the state at bay
is part of what allows for the
conception that people are deserving of
the chance independently of their
ethnicity and their race and their creed
and their sexuality to do such things as
pursue life liberty and happiness and i
see because otherwise i can't see
i can't see
where the ideas would have otherwise
emerged
during the enlightenment
well it's um you know partly the
enlightenment uh came about as a
reaction to seeing what happens if you
ground human worth in religious
doctrines such as the european wars of
religion
uh unprecedented carnage and together
with the burning of heretics uh if you
you're going back to uh scriptures
particularly in the uh in the hebrew
bible uh god commands the israelites to
engage in one genocide after another
there is no uh prohibition against
slavery there's no prohibition against
rape there's no prohibition against uh
grisly um forms of torture uh for for
victimless crimes like i like working on
the sabbath i i don't i don't think it's
very easy to come up come up with a
notion of universal human rights from
either scripture or christianity
i think the reason that it happened in
the
in the enlightenment who knows why
anything happened to the exact
moment that it did partly it was a
realization of the uh uh the internacy
incarnate from the wars of religion but
also it's uh when you when you start to
peel away um scripture and dogma and
doctrine what you're left with is our
common humanity namely uh the there's no
way that i can insist that uh only my
interests are special and you're not
because i'm me and you're not uh and and
hope for you to take me seriously as
soon as we engage in any kind of
discourse with diverse uh
other people
what we
are forced to uh to fall back on is what
we have in common namely we are both
sentient we are both rational we have
the ability to suffer we have the
ability to flourish
i made it the same stuff as you i can't
claim that uh if you don't suffer uh
that would be a ludicrous proposition
and that's what gives you the notion of
universal human rights and as government
as a derivative means of about pursuing
those rights as opposed to say um
divinely ordained um monarchy yeah so
it's so hard in discussions like this
because it depends to some degree on
your time frame and also on
whether you take the broad picture or
you concentrate on the details to some
degree because
like i mean i've got no objection to any
of the
descriptions of the horrors of religious
tribalism that you just laid out i mean
i would place that
more in the domain of tribalism than in
the domain of religion because i think
the tribalist tendency is the war-like
tendency
that the government
although the the most severely punished
heretics are often those within the
tribe those are the ones where they
really want to burn at the stake as an
example
uh so it's not it is i think there is
tribals and i think there's also um a
kind of
puritanical uh
uh emphasis on the on on pure essence
that anyone who contaminates the body
politic must be um uh expelled uh yes
there's definitely there's definitely
that and well you see that with taboo
violations in absolutely in tribal
system and authoritarianism the idea
definitely
that challenging a legitimate authority
is itself inherently uh evil it's not uh
the idea that criticizing the leader is
essential to the health of a nation
which is constituted by the idea of
democracy and freedom of speech you you
have the ability to make fun of the
president on that yes
and and and the moral obligation to
and moral obligation to it and that is
that's a deeply unintuitive uh feeling
that the natural human tendencies to we
we know this from the work of people
like
rick schweiter and john height and uh
and others is that les majeste uh
attacking the king is a uh a mortal sin
that legit that hype
hierarchies are themselves often
moralized that's a natural human idea
that was kind of i guess as we say
deconstructed or rejected uh during the
enlightenment including the rationale
for government laid out in the
declaration
it's a funny thing because
what i see happening is that over the
thousands of years of of religious
thinking let's say that that went on in
the west is that
what emerged initially was the idea that
there was something
akin
to deity that characterized human beings
and that's stated very early on in the
religious tradition and in a very
surprising way partly because it's
distributed between men and women
equally and it seems to be partly a
creative function in that human beings
partake in the co-creation of existence
and partly an ethical function in that
we're called upon to
act courageously and truthfully and and
that's that's that's the core idea i
think that's expressed in genesis and
it's it's a it's a really
sophisticated and demanding idea and
then i see it
like the mustard seed that that's part
of the parable in the in the new
testament it's this tiny idea that takes
root and against incredible odds
manifests itself across the centuries
until what we get is
an increasing
realization of the universality of
humanity and that that constitutes part
of the core of the enlightenment and
you know
you you made arguments about religious
sectarianism and and also the and
and religious like tribal warfare but
the funny thing is is that
i would say that the critics of
your defense of the
western enlightenment project
might
point to the same
details in some sense and to say well
look at the consequences of
enlightenment thinking there's been
endless
warfare since the enlightenment there's
been a tremendous
generation of destructive technology
um the
the negatives
which you can point to
case by case and piece by piece arguably
outweigh the positives i mean i
certainly don't believe that but people
could make that case and so it's not so
difficult when you're when you're trying
to take a
a long view of history
to decide
what
which part of the melody you focus on
like is it the deep yeah
or is it the details that that that seem
to work against those themes
yes well i i of course talk about the
trajectory historical trajectory of
warfare in uh some detail in the better
angels of our nature with with something
of a
and it's certainly not true that wars
increased after the enlightenment
they're quite contrary
if you look at the percentage of the
years that the great powers of the day
were at war with each other it actually
goes goes down starting in the
17th century um great power wars don't
even occur anymore we haven't had one
for about 65 years but the it is what
happened was that that in the centuries
after the
18th century there were two trends that
went in opposite directions which is
that wars actually got shorter and less
frequent but the ones that did occur uh
got deadlier that is
the countries got more efficient at
killing more people in a shorter amount
of time partly because of the of uh
weaponry but also just because of uh
social organization being able to
conscript large numbers of uh young men
and then to send them to the battlefield
as cannon fodder until and a lot of that
was driven actually by
counter-enlightened ideologies of
nationalism which
led to both
both world wars then um starting in 1945
for the first time wars became less
frequent uh shorter and less deadly and
so the first time in i think in human
history you have a systematic move away
from
occurred after 1945 with the formation
of the united nations with a kind of
unprecedented universalism kind of
global consciousness including all
races all religions still not of course
universally accepted but even as an
aspiration about that's something that's
pretty new in human history it did not
occur during the time of the european
enlightenment in the 18th century uh but
i think it it was the
um the consolidation of uh enlightenment
ideals including the formation of the
united nations which was called for by
by emanuel kant in his essay a perpetual
peace which of course did not happen at
the time but it but we've enjoyed it
since and crucially for the universal
declaration of human rights the united
nations now the sustainable development
goals you have people coming together
nations coming together some of them not
from a judeo-christian tradition by by
any means but who can agree on things
like well it's really better if people
live than if they die of disease it's
better if babies don't don't die in
their first year of life it's better if
kids go to school it's better if we
don't go to war it's better if we have a
clean environment all these things that
we have in common because we're human
beings
on the
lack of utility of unnecessary suffering
something like that and maybe the even
the lack of
the utility of
unnecessary malevolence
that's something you don't need to be
all you need to do to endorse that is be
a human and have the ability to just to
suffer or to flourish
so okay so let me switch this a bit if
you don't mind
um and i'd like to
speak a bit more personally
if you would um
what's the consequence
for you
over the last year of
this
increasing public
exposure and also controversy and what
do you think just out of curiosity about
being associated with this
loose
idw you know which
no one really joined but just emerged
out of the blue i mean i think all the
people in it in some sense you're the
most surprising
member because
well
well yes
you may be the prototype uh
but uh and you know and i am uh more
personal i think it just comes from
being uh just
not uh not having uh drunk the kool-aid
of uh of political correctness
identitarianism social justice warfare
uh wokeness as long as you're you're not
uh part of that tribe as long as you
haven't signed up to that then uh you
get associated with this uh
this of course whimsical humorous entity
called the uh intellectual dark dark red
right right so so you defined i mean
it's a joke because of course there is a
dark web right
so well it's a joke in all sorts of ways
because it's a ridiculous club i mean
i've been trying to figure out what
characterizes the people who've been
loosely aggregated in that association
you know and i think that
um a certain
fortunate independence is part of it
you know that almost everyone in that
group has their own
means of support i mean you're a
university professor obviously and that
could be taken from you but i mean you
have nine books and many of them are
best sellers and like you you have the
means to keep yourself operating as an
independent being
um without being
dependent on any
necessary external bureaucracy and i i
also have and i also have tenure which
means that i'm a little harder to fire
than most people in most jobs right
right exactly
so that gives me a certain i used to be
cynical about that about ten years it's
kind of a a unique sinicure of
university professors but there is part
of the initial rationale maybe giving
you some degree of intellectual
independence i'm really coming to
appreciate the night oh yes
ten years like the canadian senate
is
useless except when it's absolutely
necessary
right yeah yeah i think it's really and
politically of course the people in this
i mean there is no there's no as you
said there is no such thing as
intellectual dark webs except it's the
kind of joke but the people who are are
uh connected to it i think have a
certain amount of uh
unwillingness to
uh to kowtow or bow down to some of the
pieties that have become uh orthodox on
many college campuses and in some of the
uh elite uh media because politically
the the people who've been connected to
it are uh are pretty diverse they're
they're very different they're they're
very there's there's almost the complete
range except
for the absence of people who are
politically correct the other thing
that's very interesting about the group
two other things i would say is that
they've been very effective users of
social media
and also
they don't think that their audience is
stupid
you know yes i think that's i i think
that is that is a a true and it's one of
the keys to effective teaching to
effective communication uh one of the
the first bits of advice i got when i
made the crossover from academia to
popular writing from an editor at a
university press she told me the mistake
that academics often make when they uh
try to reach a broad audience is they
talk down they assume that their
audience is not as upright as they are
so the key is assume that your audience
is your intellectual peer but they
happen not to know some stuff that you
know right i offer that also as uh
writing advice in my book the sense of
style but you're but you're also right
that this
the independent-minded
uh people that we've been talking about
uh try not to use um
uh insults and put downs not uh as a
means of argument not even so much um
the audience being stupider but rather
being evil that if you don't agree with
me then you are a uh a reprehensible
human being
yeah this is definitely that's
definitely a mistake
with within the bounds of that group
let's say i think it's a brand mistake
let's say whenever that happens
so well and of course if that defines
the the kind of uh
uh
political
politically correct social justice uh
warfare that these people are reacting
to namely that the uh
the mode of argument that i think we're
all trying to move to to distance
ourselves from is that if you don't
agree with me then you are a moral
critic
right right and so okay so now what's
been the personal consequences for you
like you've been at the center of a fair
bit of controversy and i mean it's very
difficult to have a series of
best-selling books for example and
speaking tours and so forth without
being controversial in some way because
it probably indicates that you're not
saying anything of any real novelty or
importance but
what how has it affected you and and has
it been a net positive or a net negative
and then how are people reacting to you
oh it's unquestionably a net positive
and at least so far i have uh i've
certainly escaped the
uh kind of the outrage mobs that we know
can be uh
aroused by
advancing
[Music]
heterodox opinions um i have gotten you
know some anger i have i was uh subject
of a rather bizarre incident where uh a
panel that i was on uh called the
political correctness uh like donald
trump where some of my uh my remarks
were uh spliced in the video that was
then uh uh cited by the um
by the by alt-right and neo-nazis which
led to a kind of denunciation on the
left fortunately in my case i can't
complain because the new york times
stepped into my defense jesse singal
wrote an op-ed
with my photo adorning it saying how
social media are making us stupid and
using the attack on me as evidence for
the mythology of social media so i came
out of that uh uh
unscathed
on the other hand i do live in in some
degree of fear that
the mob could turn on me at any moment
uh there was a wonderful uh
um essay by by neil ferguson expressing
a similar fear he said well
my wife is made out of uh um a braver
stuff than i tells me not to worry the
interior well she's made of braver stuff
than almost anything else in the world
so i don't know that
that was the joke of course his wife
being herself
one of the bravest people on the planet
but that was a a sly little bit of humor
for those who know his personal
situation
and a reminder that people have
withstood uh much fiercer attacks than
any of us have to worry about
right right right and how are people
responding to you in public like when
you're out in public i mean you're a
you're a rather striking figure you're
easy to recognize
but what happens when you when you go
out well how it's not foreign to you
oh it's uh uh it's positive i have
nothing to complain about um people
people recognize me and i expect after
this uh
what we're doing now airs that i'll be
recognized uh even more because i know
that you have uh
quite a broad and diverse uh following
uh but in uh also in person as we know
people tend to often mitigate the kind
of animosity that is easy to express in
uh when when you're uh anonymous in
behind the uh
the shield of social media removing
anonymity so people are are much more
civil face to face
uh i have gotten uh you know a lot of uh
of
of warmth um i've gotten to my surprise
a number of people writing to me saying
that i have been good for their mental
health
as including my quillette essay even
though technically like you i'm a
psychologist unlike you i'm not a
clinical psychologist i have no
confidence whatsoever in treating
anxiety depression psychological
problems but for them and i even have to
explain to people and ask me what what i
do for a living i tend i tend to avoid
saying i'm a psychologist even though
that's what my degree is
the people assume that i'm a clinical
psychologist which i'm not so i
sometimes have a cognitive scientist
because no one has any idea what that
means you know i think you've been good
for my mental health well that's what
some people for the first time in my
life i i say i've kind of earned that
credential but some people write in it
they say i just i'm so uh dejected and
discouraged and downtrodden by reading
the news that when i come across the
data that you've presented that humanity
has been improving it actually is good
for my mental health i don't feel as
despairing for uh for my children for
myself but for the future of my country
well that's a big deal and well and
you're also it's more it's more than
that it's not it's not only that you're
saying
it's deeper than that for a couple of
reasons i mean first of all
you're a credible source and like
um naive optimism is
worse than cynical pessimism i think
because it's too fragile it's too easily
damaged but your optimism isn't naive
it's it's data based and it's well
researched and so you can go in there as
a pessimist
like as a powerful pessimist and you can
think oh
oh well look at that look at that and
and look at that and and it's not just
one or two things it's
enough things so that it starts to be a
story and you think oh well
maybe we're not going to hell in a hand
basket quite as fast as we thought we
were and then he's not necessarily yeah
well at least not necessarily yes well
that's that's something but then there's
a there's an
implicit message there too which is
perhaps the enlightenment message itself
which is that
well not only are things getting better
but human beings are the sorts of
creatures that could make things better
if they chose to
and that's that's a
radical message i think i mean one of
the things i've noticed about what
people respond positively
to in my lectures is my
insistence to them that
they could be
they may not be
but they could be
powerful forces for good and powerful
beyond really in some ways beyond the
limits of their imagination is that
human beings unbounded
rationally even from an enlightenment
perspective independent of the
metaphysics is that
we do have the capacity to address
incredibly complicated problems and with
good will and caution and a certain
degree of intelligence we can
actually
make them better and i think that that's
a deeply
positive message especially for young
people who've been raised on
nothing but a steady diet of
disenfranchisement and like nihilistic
pessimism about the future
indeed and uh and it has been a source
of tension in my own um intellectual
autobiography because and i i
i note that i'm not
an optimist about the human condition by
um but by ideology or by background in
fact i wrote a book called the blank
slate on the modern denial of human
nature arguing that we're we're not
blank slates that we are equipped by
evolution with a not a lot of motives
some of which are not not so
pleasant not so conducive to human
well-being like tribalism like
authoritarianism like uh like greed like
cognitive illusions like self-exception
but that what what
shifted my worldview was really coming
across data that came as a as much of a
surprise to me as to anyone showing that
violence has gone down and poverty has
gone down and prosperity has gone up and
then have trying to resolve that that
tension how could we as a species both
burn our burn each other alive and
engage in rape and discrimination and
genocide i mean the other hand somehow
managed to power this improvement and i
think it comes from the fact that we
have we're
cognitively and psychologically complex
we have a number of ugly motives but we
also have some modicum of empathy we
have self-control we have cognitive
processes that allow us to reason we
have language that allows us to share
our ideas and if we manage to channel
those with the right institutions with a
commitment to free speech to democracy
to science to empirical testing
then we can mobilize the better angels
of our nature as abraham put them and
and kind of eke out bits of improvement
despite our worst selves i think it's
quite comical that you used a religious
cell
analogy
title i mean because i think
part of the case that you're making
um and i would say this is a narrative
case to some degree is that
despite the depth of human depravity
which is definitely something that you
did discuss in
the blank slate although not as
intensely as some people have
that good
so to speak has the capacity to triumph
over evil and and sorrow despite the
depths of both of those and that that is
also an unbelievably optimistic message
because i don't believe that you can be
a credible voice for
optimism
and and
and uh what would you say uh uh
someone who celebrates the human spirit
unless you're very cognizant of its
depths because otherwise you're just not
informed
you're just battling the right enemy
that's right and you have to
i think value the
hard-won human institutions and norms
that don't actually necessarily uh come
naturally to us um like the rule of law
like uh like free speech like empirical
uh basing arguments on empirical data
things that are have to be
uh inculcated every generation uh we're
not doing such a good job with this
generation i sometimes think uh but it's
because of these
these games that we've invented that
bring out our better side that we have
been able to overcome our our uh our
inner demons our darker angels
i wonder sometimes too i wonder what you
think about this i mean
you know when i grew up and when you
grew up um
you know from the end of world war ii
until let's say 1989
there were real reasons for apocalyptic
thinking in in my estimation you know
they the
massive buildup of the thermonuclear
arsenal and the
constant
tension and testing between
especially the soviets and and the
western bloc
um
the times we came so close to nuclear
annihilation i think
for
several generations
and then also in the 60s the discovery
of human beings as a as let's say a
planet transforming force on an
ecological level i think there were real
reasons for people to be
terrified into a kind of apocalyptic
pessimism
and i kind of wonder sometimes if
one of the things that you're not
battling against is
what would you say is is the revelation
that that period of time in some sense
is over is that that particular
apocalypse god willing has been
reduced substantially in probability
and we can now start to think about the
future in a positive way again but man
it was 45 years
you know and not counting world war ii
which i think we probably shouldn't
count it was 45 years where everyone was
well being being taught that if they put
themselves under their desks as
elementary school
that was going to protect them from an
atomic blast
and so i want to know that that is
coming out of that
no that's true i think 1989 truly was
momentous uh it was the end of the cold
war and the worst threats of uh nuclear
exchange it also led to a decline in the
number of proxy wars in
asia and africa and
south america which people don't
appreciate you look at the
horrific wars that are taking place now
such as in yemen and syria and you might
think that we're in a uh unprecedented
area of warfare but this is nothing
compared to the 70s and 80s where africa
was in plains
the war in vietnam killed far more
people than the wars in iraq and
afghanistan and syria
combined
and there were threats like uh the the
yom kippur war in 1973 richard nixon
raised the level of nuclear uh alert
something that has not happened since
uh these really were perilous times
there's
quite a apart from the cold war iran and
iraq bought their version of world war
one which threatened to choke the flow
of oil out of the persian gulf bringing
the world economy to a halt and then we
lived through that so people forget how
um how how awful the 60s 70s and 80s
were in terms of right well and there
was also the fact that well in africa
and in south america i would say in
particular
those proxy wars also
being also ideological wars absolutely
stifled economic development both in
south america and in africa and i think
one of the reasons that we've seen this
unparalleled
improvement in economic conditions let's
say
oh it's obvious in china because of
their market reforms but in africa is at
least in part because there aren't there
isn't a coterie of
insane soviet dictators dictating
economic policy to african leaders
that's absolutely counterproductive and
pathological and so just by removing
that source of of of
trouble
much less adding anything new and good
just by getting that source of trouble
the africans have been able to
free themselves from the worst excesses
of the most foolish economic theories of
the 20th century and i really think it
started to manifest itself in the 2000s
that was part of it and there is the uh
each effect as the others so that
poverty makes civil war more likely and
uh vice versa because war is has been
called development in reverse
and that nothing is worse for an economy
than if uh schools are being blown up
and people pulled out of their offices
and shot and institutions destroyed as
quickly as they can be built markets
transportation networks uh but also if
countries are poor and then it's true
that marxist economic ideas make
countries poor then it becomes
more attractive to join militias and
sure
rebel groups because the government
isn't doing anything for you and you've
got a lot of young men who have nothing
better to do uh with their time bill
loyalty is commanded by the incompetent
government um and then of course uh both
superpowers would fund the insurgency
movements that opposed uh
whichever government the uh the other
superpower was supporting so right now
amplifying the problem consequently
amplifying the problem yes people forget
when people talk about what a terrible
state the world is in now they often
forget how awful the cold war was for
the uh
what we now call the developing world
being called the third world
right right right which is okay so so
let let me close with this if if if you
would we've had a good conversation
um
what what
what are you
working on at the moment that's
occupying you that you have hopes for
and
what are your general hopes let's say
for the next three or four years i mean
your career is
ascendant in a manner that is true of
very few people and you have a
tremendous global impact i would say all
things considered and one
that as far as i'm concerned is
overwhelmingly to the good
what's next for you and what would you
like to see happen in the future for you
over the
over the next few years
well for for the world i would certainly
like to see a push back against
authoritarian populism and a momentum
going back to the forces of
uh
of humanism cosmopolitanism of globalism
of democracy
against the uh identitarian politics
primarily of the
uh populist right since they are in
power
but also of the the campus left
but the uh renewal of the the narrative
that we
if we think about what we all have in
common as human beings and if we apply
our brain power overcoming our our uh
cognitive limitations then we can solve
problems uh climate change being a big
one i have my own uh views on climate
change i'll express them in a new york
times editorial it's coming out in a
couple of days it will work oh i'm
looking forward to is that gonna get you
in trouble
uh yes it will uh and i'll we'll leave
i'll leave that as something okay
okay well i'm looking forward to that
i'm looking forward to seeing what you
think it's a very complicated problem
it is a very complicated problem but uh
and i think some of the activists are
making it uh making it more complex and
making worse but i'll leave that as a
little uh enigma uh until people check
out that article although there was a
huge enlightenment now okay
and academically and academically i've
done a um a number of studies over the
years taking off from an interest in how
language is used in a social context uh
for a large part of my career i studied
language and it made me curious about
why we don't just blurt out what we mean
so much of the time we issue failed
threats
um sexual commands that are kind of
folded between the lines uh we show a
salary we beat around the bush we hint
we use youth
that led me to the concept of uh common
knowledge in the game theorist sense uh
i know something you know something i
know you know it you know that i know it
i know that you know that i know that
you know how it happened tonight
or not cases where we each know
something we're not so sure that the
other guy knows that we know it i think
that's
i think it's hugely powerful in our
social and emotional lives and i have a
i'm going to start writing a book in two
years whose tentative title is don't go
there common knowledge and the science
of civility hypocrisy outrage and taboo
that sounds that sounds it sounds
extremely interesting one of the things
that i've observed you know is that
people
people have a hierarchy of values and
that
the
deeper in the hierarchy the value is
embedded
the more
experiential reality is stabilized the
more it's united under a single goal and
the more it's brought
in out of uncertainty
and i think we have rules that are like
don't disrupt
too much of someone's map territory with
any given utterance
and so we we tend a bit to play on the
periphery you know like it might be too
much for you to stand to be outright
objected by or rejected by someone that
you're sexually attracted to you know
because
it casts light on your validity as a
acceptable source of dna let's say
but to play a bit
and to tease a bit
and allow you to
accept uh
carefully
and casually delivered playful rejection
without it having to go way down into
the depths of your character it's like
to me it's like a minimal necessary
force doctrine
i said
sorry about that technical snap yes i
think there is there is there is a lot
to that just the ego threat of being uh
rejected but in addition uh we have
we divide our social relationships into
qualitative different categories
and um
a a sexual relationship really is
different from a friendship or a
workplace relationship uh it is an
inescapable fact that often people are
sexually attracted to each other
sometimes one attracted to the other but
not not vice versa
all too often indeed
there is something that is uh inherently
threatening about a say a professional
relationship with chronic friendship if
the
sex is uh kind of out there if you blurt
it out even though paradoxically
so any grown-up knows that there's got
to be sexual attraction in a lot of
heterosexual uh relationships that are
not over asexual
uh so he might know it she might know it
but uh as long as he doesn't know that
she knows that he knows that she knows
uh that he knows it then you can work
under the fiction that the
relationship is 100 platonic or 100
professional there's something about
learning it out which generates common
knowledge you decide can deny that the
other one knows that they know it right
unequivocally changes the qualitative
nature of the relationship once it's as
we say once it's out there it's out
there you can't take it back the cat is
out of the bag the bell can't be on
wrong
relationship i wonder too if do you
think it's because
the explicit statement
imagine that you have implicit
motivations
and many of them and as implicit
motivations they have a relatively low
probability of being manifested but when
you
formalize that implicit motivation in
speech do you suppose
you move the probability of enacting it
up the hierarchy and therefore posed
more of a threat to the other person
is that that the speech is somehow
closer to action than the i think so but
i think it's even i think it's even
deeper than that i don't think it's just
sort of an analog shift along the scale
there's something qualitatively
different about learning something out
is it that's for sure
i think we we subdivide our uh
relationships into into different types
authority um uh subordinate
um
equal
sharing and uh
communality of interest
uh exchange and these can take place
over different uh resources over
money over sex over uh aid and uh we
don't
we are very attentive to which one holds
between a given triad in a particular
time each one is a different
coordination game as the game theorist
would put it where we both win if we're
on in the same cell if we're on the same
page but if we're we have discrepant
understandings then there can be in mild
form awkwardness embarrassment in the
extreme case shock
yeah well it's reminiscent of the
problem of dual relationships that are
often talked about in professional
ethics
you know that
it's very of course very difficult to
have a unidimensional relationship with
someone but you're constantly warned
ethically not to for example if you're a
clinical psychologist not to make a
friend out of your client
and to say nothing of our sexual
partners well yes to say absolutely
nothing of that yes exactly these sorts
of things happen between professors and
students and so and i think to some
degree they're inevitable but
the dual relationship problem also means
that you end up playing
at least two games with different
outcomes and so the aims become blurry
and the degree of
conceptual confusion also increases and
now i'm not exactly sure why making that
explicit would necessarily make it worse
but it does seem to be associated with
an uh what would you call
un
an unwise complexification of the
situation
absolutely and this is it is that kind
of
social emotional uh dynamic that i will
be writing about in in that don't go
there exactly that paradox
well i'm very much looking forward to
reading it and
um i'd also one of my dreams by the way
i don't know what you think about this
um i think it would be fun
and i suppose this is perhaps an
invitation
i think it would be fun to sit down with
you and ben shapiro and have a talk
about religion and the enlightenment and
and the state of the modern world i
don't know if you'd ever be interested
in doing something like that not a
political discussion you know but uh but
uh because i think there is there is
something to be fought out in a serious
way
between
the enlightenment types like you and and
like sam harris for example because i
would put him in the same well not in
the same category but in a similar way
yeah no i think we're we're we're
there's a lot of overlapping yeah yeah
and and and then people like sara like
ben and i who are and maybe the the
union and analysts uh for example who
tend to view
the historical movement towards
increased
freedom and prosperity as a longer
process
there's really something there that
needs to be hashed out and it's really
complicated and it might be fun to have
a conversation about that at some point
if you
if you're ever interested in if you
ever have the time
i i accept the invitation
all right all right well i'll talk to
ben because okay
i think we could have a good
conversation you know and and and scrap
it out a bit um and see if we could get
somewhere because like i like i really
liked your books you know i i really
liked enlightenment now and i regard
myself
in many ways as
as a pro enlightenment figure i mean i'm
very scientifically minded i've done a
lot of of of empirical research and
learned a tremendous amount from it and
i certainly believe that the mastery of
science and technology has been
a major contributor to the furtherance
of of human well-being and and there's
something to be said for the solidity of
an objective materialist view of the
world
but there's there's a element there that
seems to me to be
troublesome that that leads to a kind of
nihilism which which interestingly
enough you happen to be fighting with
some of your optimism which is quite
quite nice to see
but i think there's fertile discussion
there to
to to reconcile
maybe to reconcile some of the
unnecessary tension between the
different streams of thought that have
made western culture and world culture
for that matter the
remarkable
creation that it actually is
i i think that could be fruitful indeed
all right well
is there anything else that you'd like
to mention to people any forthcoming
talks you have or public appearances or
things you'd like to draw their
attention to or
are we
are we at the end of a fruitful
discussion
uh
the problem is we could we could just
keep going uh so where where to start i
will be i i'm uh often on the road i'm
often given public public uh lectures
and discussions i have one i'm having a
public event with paul krugman next week
at brown university it may not be next
week by the time this uh circulates
maybe the past tense by then um but yeah
on my website i have a list about the
video okay okay okay well it's pretty
fun to see that there's a public
audience for this sort of discussion
who would have guessed much more
much more than anyone would have guessed
just uh about five years
and debate absolutely
another reason for optimism
let's hope
very nice talking to you and thank you
very much for taking the time and um
good luck with your
your talks and your
and your academic endeavors and with
your attempts to
help people
understand that
there's
reason to be hopeful now and perhaps
even more reason to be
hopeful
in the future and about people that's a
hell of a thing for someone who doesn't
think there's a blank slate
indeed thank you jordan thanks for
having me on great pleasure talking with
you thanks very much okay thank you
let's stay in touch
bye bye
goodbye